Women decide whether or not they like a guy
within 15 minutes of meeting them.
That’s a full 14 minutes and 59 seconds
longer than YouTube viewers.
Welcome to DNews, I’m Ross Everett.
Women’s intuition, aside from being the
name of my new fragrance line, is a very powerful
thing.
Not unlike my new fragrance line.
From the moment a woman lays eyes on a possible
mate they’re analyzing their traits, deciding,
“do I want my offspring to have these?”
How do we knows this?
Well, findings from the Case Western Reserve
University in Cleveland Ohio has been doing
experiments on the brains of… fruit flies.
Ross, are you saying that women have the brains
of fruit flies?
Not at all… men do too.
Here’s a fun little factoid: fruit flies
are regularly used for research because they
share 60 percent of human genes.
So when someone says you have a flea brain,
they’re not far off.
Our brains share six of the same chemicals
that transmit messages as well as have the
same division of regions that process sound,
sight and smell.
Think about that next time you’re about
to make a big decision.
When studying these fruit fly brains, scientists
identified one single gene that, when mutated,
rendered a female completely incapable of
deciding on a mate - even when a male is trying
really hard.
Poor guy.
From there, scientists were able to map this
courtship gene to a small number of excitatory
neurons located in just three distinct regions
of the brain - two of which they never even
knew had anything to do with mating behavior.
So it’s that tiny number of neurons that
helps a lady-fly decide whether she’s impressed
by all his dancing, singing and pheromone-releasing.
And if it takes a male any longer than 15
minutes to win her over, that’s pretty much
a “no.”
So, if you want to get a big consensual YES
from a partner, remember to always put your
most exciting foot forward.
And if you get rejected, maybe it’s not
you - maybe her excitatory neurons are just
malfunctioning.
Do you find yourself gravitating towards more
exciting options?
Let me know in the comments down below.
Remember to like this video and subscribe
to DNews for more science-y type brain things
on the regular.
And also, if you would like to hear more about
the changes to California’s sexual consent
law you can check out this video where I lay
it all out in the simplest
of ways.